[موسيقى]
بلشت بالرسم اعين المدرسه من انا وصغير
برسم مع دفاتر مدرسه وشوي على الحيطان بس
رجعنا
وكنت كتير معجب بالنواب السياسيين كانوا
يزورونا من وقت لوقت وكنت ارسمهم
انت ارسم على كل واجهه المحلات بالاعياد
زينهم ويطلع مصروفه في شركه ورقه كبيره
عملت مسابقه بين كل المدارس واخدت الجائزه
وقتها بهالمسابقه كتب منهن كتير الفنان
الكبير الهولندي
اللي بعد متاثر فيه لهلا وكتاب عن
الفنائيين يلي هي حضاره عمرها 6000 سنه
كان الفن تبعهم مبني على الشخص البسيط
مشدود لفوق من الفخار من التراب نفس الوقت
موجود الذهب والالوان وخليت تمثال الفينيه
يصير ملون على طريقه يلي انا بشوفها بيعكس
نور وعتمه لحتى وصل الفني
بعد وجودك بفرنسا عائلتنا تعرضت لمقاسات
اثرت فيه كتير
عملتلي ثوره بقلبي وبفني حتى بتفكيري صرت
تشوف الالوان غير ما تنشوفها قبل كنت
تشوفها الوان حلوه وفرحه
بس بنفس الوقت
في خط اسود
[موسيقى]
البرامج فرنسا واخدت بحدود ست سبع جوائز
عالميه يلي هن تقدير لفنا
الهندسه قد ما اعطتني انضباط
فين عطيني حريه
وخليها ريشه تضرب
وتفرجي للعالم شو عم تعطي شو عم تعمل
[موسيقى]